more than 20 million people are under
severe weather alert this morning
throughout the Northeast flash flood
warnings were issued in New York New
Jersey Pennsylvania and Washington DC
this massive system already hammered the
Midwest it toppled trees overturned cars
and brought widespread flooding DeMarco
Morgan is in Moline Illinois where the
water is rising to mark oh good morning
to you good morning to you as you can
see behind me the Rock River right here
is already 2 feet above its flood stage
and it's expected to rise even further
and although the rain may have stopped
officials say their work has just begun
under clear skies residents survey the
devastation caused by the latest round
of severe weather and Kentucky homes are
found to rip from their foundations
vehicles swept away in the storm are
pulled from water rain may have stopped
but in many places flooding remains a
real threat in algonquin Illinois
homeowners raced to hold back the rising
water it's gotta get done not even
thinking about it
further west aerial footage shows the
town of Galena completely submerged
after the Galena river overflowed and
Wisconsin where a state of emergency has
been declared the town of Darlington
sits empty all roads leading into town
have been closed when you get the river
going up I mean oh you can really do is
watch it go up but there's not a whole
lot you can do to stop it
and just to put things into perspective
the ground where we are standing was dry
about four hours ago the river is
expected to crest sometime tomorrow
charlie thanks to Marco